well my attitude like media is
a big issue obviously and my attitude
toward
all of that is the culture is toxic
like here's the thing like probably
esselm
is the place where the idea was born
that there are healing images that you
can heal
your body and your mind through
the images that you hold in your head
but i
never heard a really intelligent
discussion
of the implication of that if there are
healing images
there are destroying images
there are sickening images there are
toxic images
and you can bet which are being pervaded
in the mass culture because
the purpose of capitalism is to imprint
its products in your mind and shock
is an excellent way to do it and the two
areas where as a primate you can be
gotten that most quickly is in the area
of sex and violence and so these themes
for commercial purposes are just played
like crazy
so my response to all of this is to er
is to say it's a mean war is what it is
it's a struggle over how shall the world
be
seen and felt and as long as you're just
consuming the means
coming down through the toxic
distribution
system you're a victim and a mark
and so what we have to do is produce
produce send stuff up the wire
and that's why i think the web is so
fascinating and as i said i think of it
as a
60 million channel tv
and so whatever your bent is
you should put your message out there
and we should all produce as much art
as possible i mean i think the leisure
and the indulgence that is permitted
us the super rich of this world and we
all
are in that class the upper five percent
of the earth's population
you can't live with yourself unless you
give something
back and the thing to give back is
share your art share your soul the
reason we are so
controlled and abused and misused by our
institutions
is because we are divided from each
other
you know they have divided us by race by
class by sex
by political style all of these ways
when in fact you know it's in
everybody's interest
to have a future to build a world where
children
can be raised with some reasonable
expectation
that social you know humanity will be
preserved so these mass media
things radio television and newspapers
that have arisen in the last couple of
hundred years
this is where a very small group of
people
literally set the agenda for millions
and millions
of people it's called top down or one
too many communication what the web
holds out
is this thing called any to any
communication
you and i can form a secret society we
can form a secret society of ten people
i can send email to 10 000 people
if i want the playing field has been
tremendously
leveled and then the quality of what we
produce
can tip the balance still further
uh so i think and the tools that are put
in our hands
now uh you know director
photoshop all of these things uh
make it possible to communicate
outside of these print created
monolithic institutions
we can't really even imagine a world
like that there hasn't been a world like
that
since late roman times and the roman
hegemony was quite cohesive
but you know if you were living in a
village
in armenia ruled by the roman procurator
it wasn't
touching you very very
uh heavily and i think what people the
idea of the citizen
is arguably toxic the idea that we all
are participating in some enormous
policy
works against individualism
i mean if you tried to nail me to my
politics people can't figure out whether
i'm a right-winger
a left-winger or what i am i tell you
straight out i'm an anarchist i am an
absolute an artist i mean i believe in
people
more than abstractions or institutions i
will always
rely on people i you know to a level
perhaps uncomfortable for you i remember
back in the 60s
my line was if you come upon a mob
you must join because the people
understand far more than you do
about what is going on and that kind of
radical
commitment to freedom is going to be
necessary
to dismantle these very very rigid power
structures that are
you know being shoved down everybody's
throat
and so the new culture i think is it is
a dispersed
virtual culture on the internet that is
not product oriented
its aesthetics should rule the world
and the best ideas should win and
but we all have to stop being consumers
we have to redefine really who we are
it's a much more courageous
role i you know i'm about 18 months ago
i moved to hawaii and i've lived in
hawaii off and on many times it was not
unfamiliar to me
but living off the grid
but with the net but you know
10 seconds away from climax hawaiian
rainforest so i can always push back
from my desk
and just take a walk in the woods i
realize i think this
is how people are supposed to live
dispersed over the surface of the earth
very little moving around vehicular
travel
is less and less defensible
off-grid solar electric
information-based
and virtual community that no one can
track or criticize because it's all
going on on the grid
i think if you're smart you should buy
real estate
in extremely remote areas because soon
there will be no remote areas from the
point of view of the net
and uh
just a very different kind of world is
coming into being it's not a good
time for organizations for massive
hierarchical
structures that depend on managerial
control and they
know it you know it's interesting that
corporations you know
don't seek to grow to the size of
nations
because it's highly inefficient you know
no corporation
has a welfare class built into it
you know what corporation has a
component
inside itself that it sends out checks
to every month for not working
well the executive class that's the
answer to that
we're not supposed to say that well i
agree there's a difference
but see you see me as a
hope for the future and they'll be
things better than that in other words
what i want to end with is telepresence
i agree but you can nothing will ever
substitute for the one-on-one
thing but on the other hand you know we
had to fly a 747
here and we had to just outrage the
environment
and assert ourselves as
part of that two percent class of
planetary controllers that
ride around in those things and it's
completely contradictory to everything i
say and believe to travel around
talking to groups of 30 40 50 or even
500
people it's a paradox i don't know
exactly how to handle it maybe it's okay
to live with the with paradox but i
am i can feel in my own life that
um i'll be 50 in november
and i can feel that there's a choice
ahead of me
which is i can continue to do this
forever
at the expense of my own personal
advancement into these very mysteries
we're talking about
or i can knock this off figure i've said
everything i have to say ten thousand
ways ten thousand times
cancel all visitors and begin to brew
and cook
and take and fly and understand and move
into it again but you cannot be a public
figure and
a practicing alchemist i don't think
so i i think it's fairly clear what my
choice is going to be or i wouldn't be
building a
house you can't find anywhere
but that's all right i mean the only way
i'm really useful
to the society is if i continue to
evolve and change
and i feel there's been a kind of
looping for a while
so if i disappear off the grid until
2005
then i'll be i'll be back for the last
act
i'm sure unless of course fate drops the
cosmic safe
on my head it's always there
because my candle yes
to disperse well that's an interesting
question are the cities
saving the planet or are they killing
the planet and
you could hold a conference with the
best minds in the world and not be able
to figure it out the cities are keeping
people confined
and you know but the environmental
destruction
isn't that a million people move on to
the rainforest it's the three ranchers
decide to clear a hundred thousand acres
population problems
are more in the line of toxic pollution
and that sort of thing
um yeah i mean i i don't know
where where it's all going it's very
clear we have engineered ourselves into
a very narrow neck
and what frightens me is i'm completely
convinced
that you don't have to put much pressure
on any society
and the first thing that goes are
democratic freedoms you know long
before cannibal tribes will rose the
streets and any of those
you know crazy cyber tech hell
futures come to be long before that
there'll just simply be no more
democratic rights
and we'll all be marching to the tune of
some ideology being handed down from
above
that's very dangerous maybe there are
technological fixes
you know one thing we haven't talked
about here but that is
interesting and you certainly should be
aware of it is nanotechnology
and you all know what that is the
the holy grail of the nanotechnologists
is something called a
matter compiler well this is almost
like pure magic a matter compiler
is something that does to objects
what a silicon graphics workstation does
to
images in other words
the matter compiler is like a computer
except that the program it runs is in
three dimensions
and it makes things and it makes them
out of sludge basically it just needs a
rich source of carbon nitrogen
hydrogen so forth and so on seafloor
sludge will do
fine and the people who are enthusiasts
for this
envision literally feeding china
out of matter compilers they're saying
we could abandon agriculture within 50
years
abandon it outlaw it if you wish
and and have a population of 10 billion
now this is something we had
contemplated that somehow we could be
cheated of
judgment that we could be so clever
that we could actually keep this con
game going
another few centuries with a trick like
the matter compiler
is it a good thing is it a bad thing
what would it mean
if you're interested in all of this read
neil steffensen's novel the diamond age
you know these nanotechnological
machines will be made of diamond
that's the natural substance the easiest
thing
to make them out of and they will be in
the air
and in the water and in your body and
they will be
invisible and they will be
and this whole debate about natural and
artificial and all that will just be
retired to the philosophy department
because
everything will be permeated with these
nano sites
and i think there's a future in all of
this i think culture has to become
virtual it has to the machines must
disappear they must become
very very small they don't have to be
given up
right now if we spent
half a trillion dollars moving in a
certain direction
well before 2012 we could produce a
technology of
what i call the black contact lenses
they look like contact lenses but
they're implants in your eyelids
not on your eye that they're in your
eyelid and when you close your eyes
there are menus hanging in space
and by looking at these menus it can
track your eye movement
and the entire culture has become
virtualized
internalized and if people are living
out of matter compilers then
the main task of humanity would probably
be forest restoration
and people could live tribally naked
apparently in an aboriginal lifestyle
except that everybody has instant access
to the renaissance exhibit on
mathematics currently being held at the
vatican library
this is possible some people live close
to this right now
not implants but uh
you know close enough and the micro
miniaturization this
these black combat lenses i'm talking
about this is not nano technology this
is just
technology uh a nano enthusiast
would say no no get it down to the size
so that you can just
inject it and you know no black lenses
know nothing if people like hans moravik
and these people
have ideas about what the future might
be that are very
you know make my thing look very
peculiar you probably
saw the interview in wired where moravik
was saying
that his great fear was that as the
network
is built as as everything becomes more
connected
the machines are learning and whatever
they learn
they pass on to each other and they're
all connected
and so a single thing learned anywhere
in the world
can be passed through the net to all
these other machines
and i think the humbling experience that
lies between here and the end of the
century
is the realization that there is no
magic ceiling on the intelligence of
machines
we are going to make machines more
intelligent
than we are in many ways in many areas
they already
are more intelligent than we are
and what it will mean when
suddenly the system awakens
to itself is not clear i mean this may
be cheap science fiction or it may be
precisely how the end of the world will
occur
this thing is being born how it will
view us
i don't know i had a sort of a
it was like a plot for a science fiction
novel that i was thinking about last
week i
realized when the when the network
becomes sentient
uh what will it do with all these human
beings
because it will analyze the situation
and realize that the human beings
pose a threat to the integrity of the
planet
but it will also analyze the situation
and realize
that the source of its own evolutionary
advance
requires keeping these biological units
in the loop
because of their creative ability in
writing code
so then i was imagining a world where
they would call
everybody but the code writers and you
would have a world
of 100 million code writers sustained in
incredible luxury
and with all full medical and all of
this
uh while the robots go about repairing
the damage to the planet and planting
forests and cleaning up rivers and so
forth and so on
i don't know whether that's a utopia or
a dystopia or
what it is i guess it depends on whether
you write code
i should tell you i don't i don't so
that was not an elitist
although i'm learning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you